some people are so agitated the monkey
mind they got too many things going on
and they're thinking okay they're trying
to sit down and write I suffer from this
and I'm feeling like wait I've also got
this person I need to connect with and
I'm kind of being drawn off course by
not being able to put the blinders on
for people that have that issue I think
learning how to calm the nervous system
is very powerful and the best way that I
know how to do that are one of the
fastest ways to bring our overall level
of sub autonomic arousal down and a
physiological Psy is a two inhales
followed by an extended exhale it's not
just a deep breath it's two inhales
followed by an exhale okay and then what
that what that does and this has been
shown several times now in humans and
other species as well as it dilates the
the little sacs of the lungs and that
second inhale dilates them a little bit
more and it pulls a little bit of carbon
dioxide out of the bloodstream so that
when we exhale we offload the maximum
amount of carbon dioxide and it
perfectly adjusts the ratio of carbon
dioxide and oxygen in the bloodstream
and lungs and sometimes it only takes
one of these double inhale exhales
sometimes somebody needs to do two or
three but that's the fastest way to
bring the autonomic nervous system down
the other thing is we talk a lot about
sleep and sleep is extremely important
certain but there are other modes of and
brain states that can allow you to
recover one of the ones that I'm a huge
proponent of and that my lab has been
studying and other labs are studying is
what many people call Yoga Nidra It's a
Wonderful practice you know just lying
down and focusing enough of your
attention so that you don't fall asleep
and enough of your attentions on and
moving it around so that you're not
really concentrating on any one thing
hypnosis is very similar deep relaxation
wandering sort of attention fairly
narrow context
but it brings the brain into these
unique states where you're neither
asleep nor awake and for people to have
trouble falling asleep or trouble
relaxing themselves these kinds of
practices are extremely useful because
they're really teaching you how to turn
off those modes of focus so you know we
live in a stressed Society some people
are stressed because they're overwhelmed
but other people are stressed because
they just don't know how to turn off
their brain and fall asleep and so if
you want to learn how to turn off your
brain and fall asleep
these practices are immensely useful
we're now looking at how daily breathing
um exercises can impact people's sleep
and levels of stress in most all of
hypnosis that's clinical involves
bringing one's State into one of deeper
relaxation not full sleep and then
thinking about some behavioral change
that one wants to make these are ancient
practices really and I think that they
were developed by people that understood
that rewiring of the brain requires
focus and deep rest what's interesting
about hypnosis is it brings those two
things together at the same moment so
normally you'll work really hard on
something work really hard then you'll
sleep and that's when the plasticity
occurs but hypnosis likely accelerates
that whole process by having people
enter a state of deep relaxation and
focus at the same time and allows those
circuits to reshape themselves so I
think these practices are really useful
and I think that sleep more sleep better
but what if you have trouble sleeping
well or falling asleep well we want to
Define what that is some people have a
hard time turning off their thoughts
it's really hard remember you can't do
it what you can do is to learn to
control that perceptual window and
distribute it so that your sense of time
starts to kind of drift off and you end
up in sleep more easily and it's a
practice that most people find if they
do it for 10 minutes a day or so they
start sleeping much better within within
a week or more you know and sometimes
more they sometimes people need some
other help like not drinking caffeine
late in the day Etc but that brain state
of no duration path in outcome analysis
is going to be the most restorative and
you can get it in wakefulness too so
taking a walk where you're just letting
your mind go is very powerful and the
other thing that's powerful is optic
flow so self-generated optic Flow by
walking running or cycling
shifts the brain into a state of
relaxation that's not seen when you're
stationary this is well this well
described in the Neuroscience literature
for some reason is not well described in
the wellness literature
but it's a real thing when you move
through space you're active you're
there's a natural calming of the brain
circuits involved in threat and threat
detection this is the basis for EMDR I
move into sensitization reprocessing the
lateralized eye movements they have
people do in the clinic that kind of
goofy looking thing that lowers stress
and the the the rationale is that by
coupling a low stress state
to the recall of the trauma it's going
to allow people to reshape their
relationship to the trauma tolerate the
discomfort